ban ray capo he was a lead singer of
some punk band and then became a yogi
hmm yeah and we should calm yo Garre and
he would come to tenth planet and he
would just he could move in ways [ __ ]
are you doing man like his body was so
he had so much dexterity and flexibility
it was impossible to like hold him in
positions like he just could move like
weight your two belts below me but I
can't pin you but he was actually a very
high-ranking guy he was really good at
jujitsu
he had this crazy yo and he also had
amazing breath work like he never got
tired like his cardio is incredible but
it was all because of his his breathing
techniques hatin Hickson would work on a
lot of breathing no yeah yeah he was out
like I've I've known Hickson quite a
long time and he always talked about
that you know when you breathe through
your nose and how you calm your heart
and yeah yeah panic breathing through
your mouth is what they would call you
know we panic breathe yeah yeah most
people know Taj but he was always about
control controlling your breath yeah and
going and he was like you know prior to
wim doing his thing and becoming sort of
well known he you know Hickson would go
sit and colds you know ice cold dreams
and just real calm through the nose and
controlled you know yeah that's in that
movie choke he's in a glacial River
yeah and he's just sitting with
neck-deep yeah and and everybody else
just dips their foot and like [ __ ] this
yeah there's like freezing cold water
just loving him yeah he's a fascinating
guy and he was really the first guy that
sort of introduced martial artists to
the power of yoga because he was the
best that stomach work he knew you know
yeah it's like freaky it's very yeah
yeah that's that called fire breathing
or some lame Breath of Fire there's like
a word for that kind of breathing it's a
fish sometimes you you you'll go to a
class and okay Breath of Fire
right that's just like that but yeah his
he could pull his stomach in and move it
side to side and
he said like he could use every muscle
in his body individually yeah like move
it independent of other muscles you also
love surfing love surfing yeah I've
given boards to Hickson for a long time
really yeah that's so cool that's
amazing how many digits you guys love
surfing yeah there's endless is it just
because of Rio and Rio is like no place
yeah it's like it's they all sort of did
jujitsu and sort of played soccer and
surf they're all on the beach so they're
kind of doing this things and some
volleyball with their feet whatever you
call that thing